one of my colleagues said to me
yesterday uh
is what the government did this week
a boost to the northern powerhouse or
does it really feel like the great train
robbery to you
well i have to i laughed to myself as a
manchester united fan when you
introduced the topic
i'm not sure who's handling uh priority
matters worse the glazer family with
united or
boris and his team with this i mean
you know they're both they're both
absolutely shambolic to be honest with
you the as my
uh
ex-chancellor when i was a briefly a
minister said i think to the ft
yesterday that
who would who would have thought
announcing a package close to 100
billion pounds could go down so badly
and
i think i think there's two problems the
first one is
uh
this government
seems to be uh
completely inept to expectations
management um
you know this is a government that's
taught i think factually somewhere
between 60 and 70 times about delivering
northern powerhouse rail in full
which which is
right at the core of the whole idea of
the northern powerhouse concept which
obviously
i'm in the middle of um
and uh they they've sort of penny
pinched um
but you know if this would have been the
first time that ever made a policy
announcement about northern powerhouse
rail it might not have gone down quite
as badly as it has but
what they've managed to do is is
disappoint virtually everybody including
manchester by the way because
as much as they still got hs2 and all
the bits of northern powerhouse rail
they haven't got what they wanted at the
station either
uh and of course the key part of the
agglomeration is it's not really linking
us up to
leads properly
which was supposed to be the priority
first part
uh of northern powerhouse rail and
indeed the integrated rail plan so
you know in isolation if it would have
just appeared from nowhere it might not
have been so bad but given everything
that's followed since uh boris johnson
became prime minister
as as we can see with the reaction
across the board it's pretty
disappointing so so both so the problem
is both substance and handling and by
the way we'll come to the football
question a bit later but um
let's uh listen to what uh grant shaps
the transport secretary said or let let
me remind you what he said that um
the
government
plan would
halve journey times in some parts of the
north uh
from
manchester to leeds and so on by
upgrading surely that's a win of some
description
well you know i've spent a lot of time
on it and i
you know i keep trying to uh
chat with real uh rail engineering
experts because indeed
if the government's plan delivers six
trains an hour from leeds to manchester
in 33 minutes
uh that is pretty good
but the the problem is uh with what they
have specifically said they're going to
do
i i'm yet to find a single technical
expert that believes it's deliverable
because they've got a new new line from
leeds to huddersfield
but from huddersfield uh on to leeds
it's essentially a a planned upgrade of
the existing one and as anybody that
travels uh across the penins on that
line never mind the m62 knows
you know the the the the line doesn't
seem to be capable enough of dealing
with what it has now never mind more in
the future so
it's just
if if one could take for 100
certainty
the great powers of digitalization uh
which which is implicitly instrumental
to this new plan then it would be
fantastic but that that's sort of
assuming that the life
and delivery of any kind of
infrastructure in the uk always works so
smoothly and we know it
we know it doesn't
the people who i suppose feel most
aggrieved are uh people of bradford who
as you i think have pointed out um have
the youngest workforce uh in the uk
unfortunately that workforce now can't
really travel to the places where there
are the the jobs is that
if you like
the central problem
that with what the government's done
that you have that it's not really
joining up
the metropolitan areas of the north
i mean you know when i in the early days
of trying to get uh the northern
powerhouse the idea adopted i used to
sort of in elegantly call it manchester
leeds pool
because if you take manchester to any of
those other three cities the distance is
less than the central line tube line in
london so the whole idea is to try and
get all the people that live within that
area
uh whether they be producers or
consumers it's about eight million
people to be able to move around as
easily as people do on the london uh
transport system and to have it all
integrated
and obviously for people in bradford
they they
they've got a they've got a sort of
token gesture of electrification from
bradford to leeds but that means they've
got to go the opposite way in order to
go to manchester afterwards and
obviously that that's like going from
say i don't know
um
richmond out to out to reading before
you come back into london so obviously
for people from bradford it's
particularly unhelpful but i would add
again trevor that you know those of us
that have been following it with great
closeness for the past couple of years
they could have handled that better
because it seemed quite obvious to me
that the bradford link wouldn't happen
but yet uh they've allowed a lot of
people to think that it would uh because
it is quite the bradford bit to do
uh and have the train going through
bradford would be quite expensive but
i've i've seen since and here's another
thing to throw in given the the politics
of all of this
and interestingly how the labour
opposition is now
seemingly saying even more powerfully
than i recall them saying in the past
that they would deliver in full
including bradford the political
pressures might come back
uh and get them to rethink again i mean
the one thing is for sure with all this
never-ending nonsense surrounding
northern transport is there's always
some other idea in the next couple of
years so i i hope in this case this is
not the end of northern powerhouse rail
because
whilst there are bigger issues than
transport northern powerhouse rail is
central to the whole idea that i helped
create
well you're talking about the politics
of it and you're right most people
wherever they are aren't going to be
paying too much attention to the detail
of it but i suppose that the politics of
this week
could look like that actually this is a
government which essentially
thinks first about the south and the
north gets the leavings in the sense
london has crossrail and nothing has
been allowed to get in the way of
delivering that uh delays higher pr
higher costs
all sorts of issues and planning and so
on uh so but crossrail is going to
happen come what may but suddenly
the north buff you're not getting the
thing that as you say everybody thought
you were going to get
well let's see whether they they they
revise that because of course
the downside of very strong expectations
creation is that it does create belief
and and
what's that a spirit and a desire and a
passion
and so and that's partly what created
the victory for them in the election but
if they want to stay in power
uh they've obviously got to show some
evidence of following through
um i i would add in addition uh i i
smell that there
is been quite a bit of the hand of the
treasury playing around to try and save
a few billion here and there in the
background but again for a strategic
government that judges risk reward of
these things properly
you know from what i can see they're
basically trying to save about 4 billion
by not going all the way through to
leeds from the original
announced plan for northern powerhouse
rail and it doesn't re given the amount
of money we're talking about here that's
about 10 of what was the original total
and that that seems to me to be a bad
risk rewards judgment from people in the
treasury as well to be honest
okay i can't let you go without asking
you what might be called the manchester
city question arising out of all of this
which is that um
i
but for fans of manchester united there
is some quite good news here because uh
the high-speed line will continue to run
from the south uh to birmingham and then
on to manchester united so that huge
percentage of manchester united fans who
don't come from manchester united
they're still going to be able to get to
old trafford aren't they
they they might find out if things carry
on the way that they're going that they
don't want to go there too much anymore
manchester united needs uh
needs owners that have uh profit with
purpose rather than uh no purpose
whatsoever completely shambolic how
they're presiding over this fiasco
complete
completely shambolic